happy hump day reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John I'm free
neither the bag let's watch this new
trailer shall we yes well courage and
get into you mean if someone killed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think you have something you want to
tell me
cool I am so excited for this movie oh
yeah this looks like such a great
whodunit I love how it's modern-day from
the first trailer I couldn't tell if it
was modern-day or not it looked like it
was a period piece well yeah it has that
sort of timeless quality because it
takes place in this old estate and
everybody has sort of high-class thing
going on so everything has a little more
fancy a little older school and it's
riffing on you know the old-school
whodunit kind of movies oh yeah I just
assumed maybe it takes place like 30
years ago or something like that I
wonder how this will this kind of tale
would ultimately play out a little bit
differently using some modern-day stuff
I know she mentioned Twitter yeah yeah
but you know they did those are the
phone recordings it's like these kind of
whodunit mysteries you know with the
cell phone technology that does change a
little bit of how the game would
actually unfold surveillance tools of
the swords the like you don't really see
much of that it seems like it's still
pretty grounded in the kind of whodunit
movies that we've seen before
I'm loving the tone of it it doesn't
feel necessarily subtle yeah anyway
everyone's performance seems to be a
little bit elevated a little bit
heightened because all these you know
very highly reputable actors are all on
that same kind of page with the kind of
tone that this movie is going for it
won't cross into cheesy or over-the-top
acting when it clearly that is the tone
of the whole picture that we're watching
and so to see all the actors on the same
page for that it just seems like they're
all gonna be having such a really fun
time doing this you know
well this almost took me back to
something like brick you know because
that's a movie that has a lot of kind of
heightened characters that borrows
heavily from noir that uses yeah
modern-day setting but with a sort of
older school mentality and I like that
it seems like he's coming back to sort
of that Sensibility but in a totally
other way with this I feel like Rian
Johnson is a pretty clever writer I'm
expecting at least a certain amount of
twists and clever refresh ideas coming
into the genre itself and yeah like
looking at the cast like you said
everybody looks like they're having a
good time and everybody has
you know like a bit of height and a bit
of color to their character now I just
got to see it I mean the first trailer
got us with I feel like the ensemble and
then this trailer brought in the
suspense and the sort of ticking clock
of it all yeah it just seems like
everything's gonna keep escalating and
keep escalating I have no idea what the
ultimate reveal is it that's what I mean
there's some of this dialogue that seems
like really on the nose talking to the
audience in a way I think it was it was
out a Jamie Lee Curtis or Toni Collette
who mentioned like the big plot reveal
or plot to us at the end so yeah yeah
and I figure we're gonna get a lot of
that kind of dialogue really kind of
sort of tongue-in-cheek this seems it to
be a very self-aware kind of movie it
may be at least deconstructive though
yeah especially of this kind of genre
yeah which is a genre that you have to
be clever to deconstruct because you
have to be clever enough to construct a
clever mystery anyway yeah you know so
you have to be it's a tall order I feel
like you know this trailer this movie in
general is putting out a confident
message even with the marketing of like
Oh Ryan Johnson whodunit you gotta
really put your chips on the table with
something like this you know cuz you
can't half-ass it you can't have a
murder mystery that is lackluster you
know that's true that's true he's great
at writing mysteries
she raised parents for nobodies I know
unexpected unexpected all right but
brick and looper awesome fly is a great
episode and I do yeah I think Chris
Evans is absolutely gonna be the scene
stealer in this but I don't know if
you've seen Stiller I things gonna be
the standout performance he's good I
love how he's got only one line in each
of these trailers but yeah he is one of
the most well he seems to have the most
specific kind of mannerisms and a little
bit of gleeful body language is
everything fun the awareness that it's
Chris Evans is a pretty versatile actor
but of course everyone mainly associated
image now with Captain America and then
kind of breaking the mold here in a
and what looks to be hopefully a
successful thriller I'm not sure these
are good right now hey the reviews are
great there these are like 98 percent
currently because I think it premiered
at TIFF and people are loving it weirdly
because it's a fan that's about a family
even though it doesn't you know feel
like a holiday movie it kind of does
mesh well with the holiday season a
season thing let's go watch family get
messed up but it'll be fun still I think
this time of year is the Jamie Lee
Curtis time of year yeah I got Halloween
last year this November we're getting
her in here next year we'll get her in
Halloween kills oh no next year will be
hollow the holding gray and then hollow
yeah technically whichever number 12 on
the actual chrono is excluding
last Jedi because there's Star Wars I
would say that as a Rian Johnson film
this looks to be his most colorful like
every frame of this movie such a
striking palette design it seems like
such a composed film all around I'm just
so excited to see what he does this
looks like the most fun he's having with
directing - because brick is a murder
mystery film there's not exactly like
funny it's more but it's a dark nor her
yeah well I'm sure there'll be a lot of
darkness to be had in this film it seems
to be like his most upbeat even with the
kind of I love the string music that you
were hearing in this trailer
old-school operatic cinematic type of
sounds and I and it said that it really
just adds to the whole suspense of it
all and we got teases a little bit of
potential I don't know for calling
action action she's gonna be some cards
there's gonna be some intrigue some
fighting you know this definitely looks
like it has a strong element of dark
comedy and there will be at least a
couple of cuz up also I think part of
the fun of whodunit like this is seeing
the mysterious
obscured killer taking people out and
stuff like that and then you know I got
imagine the families gonna get more
frenzied is the mystery unravels and
then you know these Pacific present
a good potential for action I think as
much as I think Chris Evans gonna be a
standout it seems like from the limited
amount of times he's in these trailers
that he probably dies pretty early I
would imagine
or maybe disappears for a long time then
comes back under mysterious alright guys
well are you excited for knives out I'm
gonna be watching this opening weekend
who do you think will be the standout
performer comment below you guys can
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification Bally you check us on
patreon where we do weekly Q&A Stevie
show reactions stream along several of
those shows have reaction highlights
included he does music video coverage
weekly I'd like to end this video with a
patron of the day shout out to a man
named Jake Stewart Jake I know you had a
really great birthday recently I know
we've done this before but I'm gonna
expand upon this shout out your name
Jake means God is gracious for my
understanding that's your name meaning -
your name is derived from my name your
last name Stewart can mean guardian or
warden which means that people that are
being punished for a crime they've
committed you are gonna wrongfully
mistreat them for such a long time
because that is the job of a warden you
are the most hated man amongst the most
hated people but God is chosen you to
bestow justice upon the people
mm-hmm and you know if God said so can't
be wrong right all you gotta do is tell
them you got God in your side and you're
pretty much just I don't do anything so
keep that in mind Jake because when your
career is not going where you want to go
you're gonna end up a warden because who
really wants to grow up to become a ward
and clearly God has a plan for you and
that is to look after criminals
I'm Zhou
it's like your 10th shout out sorry